our religion anti religion bandwagon
continues on back with Jaclyn at
Roseanne's kitchen table and I wanted to
talk about atheists verse agnostics this
is one of the big ones that comes up all
the time so let's can we get some basic
definition yeah can you help me yeah I'm
a layman on a simple this is your
department what is it atheist somebody
who doesn't believe in God that's it
well that's it but but it seems so much
more confusing than that it's not
actually at all and the thing is I don't
like that there even has to be a verses
there like you can be an atheist and an
agnostic agnostic actually you should be
okay so now what is it agnostic before
we start combining them an agnostic is
somebody who just does not have
knowledge you cannot prove it either way
so you have actually religious people
who claim to be you know agnostic
theists you know they believe in God but
they also admit a certain level of
ignorance which they should because
unless they have seen God and shaken his
hand they can't admit to have definitive
proof either way right you know and I
can't either
right so but they'd say that's what the
whole purpose of the leap of faith is
right that's what they that's what they
was right right the whole point is not
that you're gonna make some guy and
shake his hand on the bus right that
he's gonna come to you in hurting boy or
in a where else does he show up besides
a burning bush I don't know imaginations
all right look
um no but it's just frustrating because
you know people feel like they have to
have faith and they believe things but
that's not enough for a lot of people
they have to say oh no I know this is
true these are facts and they get mad at
you for questioning it they get mad at
you for saying well maybe there's a
little bit of weirdness going on in your
story um but yeah I know agnosticism is
just you know admitting that you don't
know so if you're an atheist
I mean I've you know you should say that
you're agnostic atheist and I've met
atheists before too that claim to know
that there is no God and they frustrate
me just as much it's like come on man
keep an open mind don't be that person
right so it seems to me that basically
atheists are just agnostics with bigger
balls right they're like one God further
right you just may I mean you just take
it to the next logical conclusion while
agnostics are kind of like hedging their
bets like right well you never know
because there's that deathbed thing
right everyone talks about the deathbed
thing like you know when you're on your
deathbed no atheist holes you know it
yeah the same thing which I know we've
talked about this poor you hate that
prick that that caused and because it's
like oh yeah York you not you know your
convictions are too weak that you know
the last moment you wouldn't be able to
hold them right very insulting but again
a lot of times actually people
commenting saying you know why can't you
just say agnostic why do you even need
to say a theist would I define yourself
by what you or not you know I don't go
around saying that I'm you know not an
Italian I'm not you know all these
different nationalities why do you need
to say that you're not all these
different religions it's honestly it's
because of our culture it's because
there's so many religions all around us
people you know you have to say I'm not
any of these to say I'm agnostic it's
just like okay but you can be religious
and agnostic so that doesn't tell me
anything you know so you say you're
atheist why is it so horrible yeah
they're like it has a negative
connotation and I'm like right so I
would say that for me I'm probably more
agnostic I stop I am - yeah like I'm cut
like I don't like I don't think I'll
tell you what I don't think I don't
think that there's some space guy
watching me and judging me and thinking
about what kind of sex I'm having don't
like I just don't I think if there is a
guy if there's some like I'm going
straight elegance but if there's stuff
like conscious thing out there the idea
that he would be worried about who I'm
sleeping with or any of that it's all
right he's not a baby then he's just a
big baby so if you think there's a big
baby up there then that's something but
I just feel like maybe something that we
don't understand some some intelligence
we don't understand created this thing
somehow and now it's off doing some far
better [ __ ] than watching us cuz for a
lot of the religious people it's just
about sex right like it's about the
guilt thing and then it's about how I
can prove that I'm better than you in
all these different ways it's about how
can i you know how can I put you down
and say that you're not good enough
because my sky daddy is not going to let
you into his magical kingdom because
you're different than me I mean that's
about what it comes down to but ya know
a theist atheist not religious assault
means agnostic to not have knowledge of
something so you can have both not
contradictory all right I think we
settle that if you're a believer and you
look really deluded
comment in the section down below just
kidding that was a joke people we
believe I'm offended yeah there's a lot
of offense contra comment like subscribe
check out Jacqueline's channel there's
an annotation right here and that is all
week